good day everyone and welcome i'm jack van horn
from the university of virginia please allow me
to welcome you to this edition of our 2020 2021
foundations of biomedical data science seminar
series this lecture series is supported by uva's
integrated translational health institute of
virginia the uva brain institute the college of
arts and sciences the school of data science and
through a grant from the national institutes
of general medical sciences it is my honor
and privilege today to welcome our speaker dr
vince calhoun from georgia state university with
additional appointments at georgia tech and emory
university dr calhoun got his uh bs in electrical
engineering from the university of kansas in 1991
followed by masters a masters of uh engineering
biomedical engineering from johns hopkins
university i'm a master of science and information
systems and from johns hopkins university um
and then a phd in electrical engineering from
the university of maryland in may of 2002. he's
conducted primary research at yale university
and spent many years at the mind institute at
the university of new mexico in 2019 he joined
the faculty at georgia state university where he
is the founding director of the tri institutional
center for translational research and neuroimaging
and data science this is a partnership involving
georgia state georgia tech and emory universities
and which focuses on improving our understanding
of the human brain using advanced analytic
approaches with an emphasis on translational
research such as the development of predictive
biomarkers for mental and neurological disorders
dr calhoun has built a career on developing
techniques for making sense of complex
brain imaging data the use of big data approaches
in neuroinformatics tools to capture manage and
analyze and share data is a major emphasis because
each imaging modality has its limitations the
integration of these data is a vital need
to understand the healthy brain especially
also the disorders of the brain dr calhoun creates
algorithms which seek to map the dynamic networks
of the brain structure um and the involvement of
genetics and how these are affected while being
stimulated by various tasks or individuals with
mental illnesses dr calhoun is an author on more
than 650 peer-reviewed journal articles and over
750 technical reports abstracts and conference
proceedings he served in many leadership roles
in the field of neuroimaging and data science
he is a fellow of the um uh institute of
electrical uh and electronic engineers uh past
chair of the organization for human brain mapping
amongst other accolades uh he's been awarded over
a million dollars uh sorry 100 million dollars and
counting in federal research grants to study the
topics of uh of neuroimaging related research and
his talk today is entitled brain-based biomarkers
a focus on the heterogeneous enhancing sensitivity
to brain disorders and change as always we are
streaming this lecture live and for recording via
youtube and if you are watching on youtube thank
you so much for joining us also our specially
selected 2020 uh 2020 2021 biomedical data
science innovation lab participants are encouraged
to submit any questions for dr calhoun by the chat
feature in their zoom sessions i'll synthesize
these questions and ask them on your behalf at
the end of the lecture and with that welcome vince
we are so excited to hear about your talk today
thanks jack it's a pleasure to be here um what i
am going to be doing today is talking about some
of our work in trying to move towards brain-based
biomarkers um but in particular with a a focus on
heterogeneity um you know and how do we use that
in in order to enhance our sensitivity um so i'll
go through kind of some some uh preliminary work
um and motivation and then i'll talk about sort
of a number of different ways in which we've
tried to tackle this issue um so i think um
when we're trying to develop you know neuroimaging
biomarkers of brain disorders or health
um there's often this sort of back and forth
between a focus on sort of individual changes
and you know canonical changes like do we can we
find something that's sort of representative right
of a group or a a set of of individuals and that's
kind of a circle or a cycle and and if you look
at the field you see studies go back and forth
between group differences individual prediction
individualized change then trying to develop more
general generalizable information so um i think
this is really kind of an important cycle and
that's a little bit what i'll be touching on today
um there have been sort of a huge increase
in recent years in studies focused on trying
to get at sort of prediction right accuracy
classification etc um this is a review from
a number of years ago where we started to look at
this and you can see you know sort of some of the
accuracies here across various uh brain disorders
uh there's a pretty big spread um there's also you
know a trend of higher accuracies with smaller end
data sets which which probably gets at some bias
but there's also you know quite a bit of
evidence that brain imaging can be useful and
accurate at predicting various aspects that may
potentially be important for clinical translation
um and we can predict you know not only do doing
sort of binary classification of you know group
a versus group b but you can also look at
sort of regression or predicting continuous
continuous measures like symptoms or cognitive
scores etc and this is sort of a more recent
review where we kind of looked at this and
a couple of the take-homes we found here
when you incorporate multiple imaging modalities
you tend to get higher accuracies uh than unimodal
you can kind of see the distribution here and
the other is that you know if you're looking at a
patient group the the accuracy within the patient
group tends to be higher than the control group
and this is probably because the emphasis in a lot
of the studies were focused on sort of symptomatic
um aspects more relevant for for patients another
another area that um that i've been uh interested
in and i think it's going to be really helpful
as we try to again move towards biomarkers
are these sort of large-scale competitions
and so this is just an example of one we did
just recently um which had a pretty good turnout
we had about 14 000 entries and this this was the
sort of the first ever uk biobank based um brain
imaging competition and it used functional mri
and structural mri almost 12 000 brains um and
it was sort of a collaboration between trends
the human brain mapping organization for
human brain mapping ieee and the uk biobank
and one of the reasons these are useful is
because you again it's pretty easy for bias to
creep in when you're trying to do classification
and prediction even if we really try hard to
cross validate keep things completely separate
competitions are a nice way to sort of try to
benchmark and evaluate algorithms from groups
that are completely outside of uh of your own
um another area that i think is is kind of an
important area is sort of um there's another
cycle that that um that i think is important here
which is sort of looking back and forth between
data driven approaches and model based uh
approaches um and i think there's there's a
um a big area of uh need for more hybrid models
that sort of blend those two and what i mean by
that is essentially using priors right so here's
an example where you know we've done quite a
bit of ica of course but one of the things about
ica is that you know it's completely data driven
so if you run it on a different set of subjects
you might find slightly different components it
might be a little bit hard to match you know etc
um you can kind of blend the best of both worlds
if you use something called spatially constrained
ica and so the way that we approach that is we
we took two fairly large data sets and we did sort
of independent ica analyses on resting fmri data
identified the components that replicated uh
between the two uh and then we used those to
derive a set of sort of component maps that we
can use as priors in a spatially constrained ica
um and so there's a number of benefits here one
of which is you can directly compare uh across
data sets very easily because the components are
essentially linked and you can see again here how
similar these two connectivity matrices look these
are basically the cross correlation between the
time courses associated with ica spatial maps uh
in two separate data sets and they're correlated
above 0.95 um actually i think this is like 0.98
or something and then importantly if we look at
group differences between schizophrenia and and
healthy controls here you can see that these
patterns also look highly similar they're a bit
noisy they're small effects but these are the ones
we're really interested in and if you threshold
these maps you're correlating at about 0.95
the other benefit here is that we can estimate
this in individual subjects right so we're just
taking the priors we're estimating a result
from one subject so we don't need a group
um and a third benefit is it it basically provides
uh sort of adaptive spatial maps and connectivity
information that we can then compare
and cross-validate quite easily
and these kinds of network-based approaches
where we're looking at sort of maps as opposed
to specific regions tend to outperform you
know region of interest based approaches
here's one example where we applied this
to uh essentially predict a response to uh
antidepressant or mood stabilizer in young adults
who came into a clinic a mood disorders clinic
um and a number of whom who were unable to be
diagnosed because they were in the euthymic
state and some of them who were diagnosed
incorrectly put on the wrong medication
and so working with beth osich and london ontario
basically scanned at baseline these individuals
and then followed them up very
carefully over a course of several years
and eventually determined which medication they
were most responsive to that worked best for them
and we use the baseline image to
predict uh that follow-up uh medication
um and we were able to do this with an accuracy
of about 95 so that was quite promising and it's
it's something it could potentially be
useful clinically especially given that
some of these folks when they're put on the
wrong medication can get can get ill and
it also hints at you know we can we can identify
networks that are most predictive uh in this case
uh and you can see that the ones that that came
out shown here in color um and that can sort of
hint a little bit at mechanism and potential
you know targets for future treatments as well
so again it's just sort of an initial and the
other thing that i like about this study is
it completely ignores the dsm diagnosis it's it's
really just looking at medication class response
um another example is uh here shown here
where we're looking at uh ect response and
so this is a treatment for major depressive
disorder um and some folks will respond uh
uh and and persist in their their response
to the treatment others will will have an
initial response and taper off and if we look
at predicting the the accuracy post ect with a
baseline um resting fmri scan we can we find about
a 78 or 77 percent accuracy in in predicting uh
the change in the depression rating scale uh that
was measured okay so so that's sort of you know
where we want to head and i think there's a lot of
potential applications there that can be looked at
but there's an unsolved challenge here which i
i didn't touch on yet in those previous results
which is we need to know what we're predicting in
order to train a model to do the prediction right
and so if we don't know that then it's called
unsupervised right or unsupervised clustering and
so you know here is an example where you know i've
clustered a data into four clusters and you can
always find you know groups of data that fall into
clusters naturally but if you take those if you
take that data and then you map say in this case
we had four um mental disorders represented each
dot here as a subject and we map the disorders
on to the the same representation you can see
it doesn't look particularly useful in terms
of telling us anything about the the diagnoses
and that's because you know the brain
doesn't exist just to tell you about
your mental disorder right it's there's a lot
of things that the brain is doing uh and uh
the data is is you know is is not necessarily
going to be reflective of what you care about
and so this is one of the reasons it's such a
big challenge so one way we've tried to get at
this is using approaches based on something
called by clustering um and and sort of
subsequent extensions that we've developed and
this approach was initially developed to look at
genetics genetic data and here is an example where
you have conditions there are h conditions here
and these are the genes and their responses
whether it was sort of on or off uh positive
or negative um you know or non-responsive and
what by clustering is doing is to jointly group
conditions and genes together so here you can
see you know uh data like this gets grouped into
two different bi clusters where genes one four
and nine show consistent on off responses to the
different um uh conditions there genes one four
6 7 and 9 show consistently positive responses
to conditions b e and f and so you can think of
this as you know so you can kind of get at here
uh looking at subgroups of individuals right
or potentially subgroups of responses or brain
patterns and so that's what led us to sort
of our initial study looking at structural
mri and so what we're doing in this case is we
we first um took some t1 uh structural mri data
segmented it and then applied ica to
those maps something called source-based
morphometry so it's like a multivariate
extension of vbm or voxel-based morphometry
we're essentially uh extracting uh maximally
spatially independent patterns of gray matter that
co-vary in a similar way among subjects and so
what we decided to do was to take these sub these
loading parameters which tell you the degree to
which a given subject expresses a given source map
uh and do by clustering on that and so we um with
the bi-clustering algorithm we're essentially
taking two components here uh and we're jointly
clustering subjects and components um together
um and this was in the case of looking at
symptoms uh in uh individuals with schizophrenia
um and healthy uh uh a healthy group as well um
and so when we're looking at symptom subtypes we
essentially found three sets of uh subjects or
subtypes one of which was uh heavily weighted
on positive symptoms and loaded on one component
here another one of which was heavily loaded on
negative symptoms and loaded on a different
component and a third one which was sort of
jointly loaded on both components and was
more generalized in terms of associated with
generalized symptoms um and so you can kind of see
where this is going this is really trying to get
at can we um you know look at the variability
in our data and see where we have consistent
sort of apple to apple comparisons and so another
example where this um which sort of highlights the
benefit of this type of an approach um is if we
extend this to sort of n-way clustering so instead
of just two we have multiple same kind of scenario
where we have structural mri and we have loading
parameters here um but we buy cluster on all the
combinations of the components um and we also
include symptoms right and so we have positive
negative and generalized symptom categories that
are also included as um as data types there
and so what we found was pretty interesting i
thought so first we have uh bi clusters here that
only include components and you can see component
numbers listed here and i know that doesn't
mean a lot the specific numbers are shown here
um after the semicolon tells you how many of the
subjects were grouped in to that by cluster and
interestingly you can see here where the certain
black circles are that we get um a significant
relationship with various symptom categories um
which does not um uh is not reflective if we don't
do the by clustering we don't find uh a strong
relationship with symptoms and the reason for
that is because what we're doing is we're sort of
focusing on homogeneous subsets of individuals um
again more of an apples to apples comparison
and within that the variability is lower and
the relationship to symptoms emerges um and
likewise we find certain patterns of symptoms that
are linked to certain components right so here
we have a component 14 is covariating these 60
subjects covari between component 14 positive and
generalized symptoms okay so this is a lot of data
there's a lot to take in here but i think it's
a really useful way to start to tease apart
some of these data sets while getting at
heterogeneity in individuals and of course
we kind of keep going here so we said well can we
apply this to fmri data and look at dynamics and
uh so uh we we did that where essentially we're
jointly clustering on windows which is basically
sliding windowed uh cross-correlation patterns
you can see shown here right uh sets of subjects
and pairs meaning individual cells within these
connectivity matrices okay so here here we've
got in you know what you're doing in dynamic
connectivity is you're essentially computing the
the functional connectivity in sort of a sliding
window fashion and then you can cluster those into
states you know patterns transient patterns
of connectivity that individuals move close
to or farther away from over time and so with the
tri-clustering approach um we basically applied it
to a large data set of about 300 plus individuals
with schizophrenia and healthy controls
and were jointly clustering as i
mentioned windows and subjects and pairs
and so what we found was again an analysis
that showed a much increased sensitivity
to patients versus controlled differences
and here you can see if a cell is white so
these are five different states that occur
at different times in different individuals
these are this is the control the patient and the
difference and all of the ones that are shown here
are significant the ones that are white are
excluded uh from the tri-cluster because they
they weren't homogeneously associated with that
set of again here you can see 3 500 windows uh
81 subjects and 619 pairs in this matrix that came
out and we found three of these were individually
linked to either generalized negative or positive
symptoms and there were actually quite a lot of
interesting results that are fleshed out more
in this paper that i've listed here below okay
another source of variability that we've been
trying to get at um is spatial and temporal
variability okay so the dynamic functional network
connectivity tries to get at that to a degree
um but um you know the the majority of temporal
dynamic studies have have focused on just
coupling between fixed regions right so the
the correlation between these two changes over
time right it goes up or it goes down but you
can also imagine spatial dynamics where maybe
maybe the nodes that you're looking at shrink or
maybe they grow or maybe they shift a little bit
and then you can have joint spatial temporal
dynamics right so so i think these these latter
two are only just beginning to be studied
in in the field there's been quite a few
studies of temporal dynamic um uh in the
field and and what we're finding is that
there's actually a lot of evidence that spatial
of spatial variability in these functional
patterns that we're seeing um this is just
sort of one initial way to kind of look at that
within each it's sort of a hierarchical
analysis so within each sort of domain
we can look at sort of sub-clusters and
how they couple differently over time
create little transient movies within within the
domain so this this is for example subcortical
network domain and you can see how it changes
over time and importantly if we look at sort
of if we look at a patient and control group
we see the coupling varies quite substantially
between the two over time in in just the spatial
aspect of the dynamics okay um and then a third
category where we're kind of getting at that is
well is well instead of just focusing on a pattern
of connectivity that you know or you know fixed
states right that occur maybe we have five states
they they occur at random times in
different individuals if it's resting data
um but maybe those states actually have some some
behavior that that that you know occurs smoothly
over time can we look for sort of motifs or
transient changes in these larger state patterns
and so those we we call statelets essentially
sort of short little transient motifs around
those states um and interestingly well why
did we do this well when we started to look
at this in you know in a patient data set we
find very striking uh differences between the
two for example the the healthy individuals are
showing much more um evidence of you know longer
recurrence right over time before it kind of
tapers off and disappears almost like a ripple
in the water whereas the the patients show more
more sort of an up and then almost off fairly soon
um you can see here the time decay it's almost
night and day right we see a fairly uh dense uh
link here when we look at time decay in in the
healthy individuals whereas there's almost very
little to nothing in the schizophrenia patients
classification you know using time delay is is
significantly higher than it is uh
when we're using uh something like
connectivity patterns for example so again this
is just another example where again trying to
dig into the data and and represent it in a
way that that captures some of that variability
okay the the other sort of elephant in the room
is always the diagnostic labels right so for
example if we're talking about schizophrenia and
schizoaffective disorder um you know some of which
are individuals that experience manic episodes
others more depressive um those are all based
on self-reported symptoms and interviews and and
they're not biologically based right um they're
useful clinically uh but they're not biologically
based so they're not really getting at the core
of the disorder and so we know that they're
they're not perfect right and so how do we deal
with that when we're trying to do a classification
study here's an example where we just applied a
technique uh trying to look at labels so
in this case a label would be a diagnosis
and we treat those labels as noisy right so we
allow them to have some error right and you you
can you can do this one way to sort of get at well
is there error or not is if you apply multiple
classifiers across you know across the data and
then you look at whether the classifiers agree
or whether they disagree consistently um and so
that gives you some evidence of of whether they're
noisy or difficult or challenging and should we
re-label them potentially and you can do this
we apply this to um this approach to some numeric
data so this is the mnist data and we took numbers
that sort of look fairly similar and kind of uh
could be confused with one another so eight threes
fives you know here's a one and you can see if we
apply this approach to basically identify the the
noisy labels and relabel them we improve uh the
accuracy up to a certain point uh so it doesn't
overestimate it actually is improving the result
in this sort of well-defined case and then we then
we decided to apply this to um structural imaging
data from uh this um psychosis spectrum study
um and we are looking at it with sort of two
different categories this this is um uh the
um the b snip uh study which which is looking at
um uh trying to define something called a biotype
um which is using a set of data to that includes
biological data and trying to identify sort of
a clinical type right and sort of ignoring the
diagnosis right so they they have in that study
uh identified uh you know three sort of biotypes
in this case they're labeled one two and three
and we also have the the dsm categories in this
case bipolar schizoaffective with psychosis
um etc and when we look at sort of original
versus cleanse which is sort of denoised
uh you can see that the accuracy you know
increases right significantly it goes up uh
quite a bit uh for these pairwise comparisons
as well as for the the all-way comparison um
and but importantly you know we've got again
in this case two different categorization um
uh approaches one is dsm one is biotype and if we
apply either one of those we see an improvement
and we see sort of meaningful separation and
when we look at the voxel-wise comparisons of
the relabeled data the regions that come out as
showing uh differences in gray matter are sort
of meaningful right and they reflect some of what
we see in previous work um and and much more with
much more sensitivity uh than what we typically
find but they're not the same right so this kind
of then gets that well what what else could we
do here you know it's it's almost like using a
prior right you're taking your dsm labels as a
prior but it's not fixed and it can shift right
if you take biotype you might get a slightly
different answer so so you know we can think about
well maybe we should use multiple categories use
all the information we have at hand or you know we
could you could you can get you know get there's a
lot of things this sort of could could lead to but
it's really trying to say well let's let's let's
ex let's just expect that the dsm categories are
error prone and not biological and and allow
the algorithm to try to update those okay
and then the last topic i wanted to touch on was
you know sort of heterogeneity in the context
of of deep learning um so deep learning has um
uh has had sort of quite a lot and see if i can
turn off my menu here hide video panel try that
whoops no i had floating meeting controls okay
i'll never i'm never gonna be able to get those
controls back but oh well um so you know here was
a sort of a so we've been looking at deep learning
for you know a number of years now um and it's
clearly beneficial clearly has some areas where it
can it can give you information that you don't get
from standard approaches um here is one more
recent study where we looked at some large end
data we used the uk biobank data and we looked at
um comparing deep learning with what we're calling
standard machine learning and so that would be
things like linear discriminant analysis logistic
regression support vector machine um and um you
know we we divided the categories into groups of
age so there were essentially five different
age groups as well as females versus males
and you can see in all cases these top two black
and blue uh bars on this graph are the two deep
learning approaches and these are all the standard
machine learning approaches and you can see
up to ten thousand subjects and even down to
you know only a hundred um where you know deep
learning is is outperforming in terms of just
the accuracy right but of course we don't want to
treat this as a black box and one of the strengths
even though it's talked about often as a weakness
deep learning you know is um giving you access to
a bunch of parameters right and those parameters
the challenge is how do how do we visualize those
but we have access to them so there are lots of
strategies for trying to visualize them um and so
for example in this case we we looked at you know
alzheimer's versus mild cognitive impairment
stay you know stable and progressive uh versus
controls and and you can you know one one way you
can do this is is something uh where you sort of
visualize the layer and you project it back into
uh brain space and you can see for example medial
temporal regions are the most informative when
we're predicting alzheimer's versus controls which
which makes sense um you know based on prior
work um you know we find about a 93 accuracy
there but more importantly for stable versus
progressive mci predicting you know future decline
uh we're getting above 80 accuracy um but it
is important to kind of go back and visualize
another way you can visualize is is to use
these sort of projections right so we can
this is using something called um t distributed
stochastic non-linear embedding or t-sne
you basically take a bunch of parameters and you
project them into a two-dimensional space which
preserves the local you know neighborhood
information so each dot here is a subject
and this is just showing that if we if we if we
go from one to two to three uh layers which is
sort of small for deep learning models these days
you start to see some interesting clusters here
uh come out for these um for these uh groups uh
this gets funny a bipolar disorder schizoaffective
disorder um and it gives you some interesting
observations and we can also then drill down
into each individual subject and visualize you
know how they look uh relative to the others
um but we're just getting started right so so
here here's another example let me again hide
the floating meeting controls okay here's another
example where we're asking the question is our
model complexity um optimal right and and so um
using resting fmri here we're comparing you know
components in different domains here and how they
are linked you know or functionally connected to
other component domains um and whether that is
that that sort of accuracy when we're trying
to predict the clinical group is improved if
we use sort of a linear relationship versus a
an additional layer versus a third layer after
that and and what we're finding is and these
are all cross-validated what we're finding is
evidence that for example you can see here the
cognitive control networks show evidence of of
needing additional layers additional complexity
their relationship is there but it's it's best
modeled it needs to it needs a more complicated
model more parameters in order to model it
uh to achieve a high the highest accuracy
so again you can see this is really there's a
whole bunch of things we can do here right but
but it's really getting at can we can we use
this information the structure of the model
that emerges from this to tell us something uh
intuitive about brain regions and brain domains
um and then i think the last example here is is
using you know deep models to try to get at the
temporal information a little bit more so you can
use you know something called convolutional neural
networks lets you leverage the spatial information
uh recurrent neural networks let you leverage you
know delays in time and so if you combine the two
uh for resting fmri data you can you can develop
a model that predicts uh from resting fmri or
from other kinds of fmri data or temporal spatial
temporal data and just as i had mentioned before
we can project down into these two-dimensional
plots here and see where the the patients and the
controls lie relative to one another in both the
training and the testing data we can visualize
which components in this case we fed in to the
model we didn't use raw data in this case we're
actually feeding in ica components and we have
individual components that are most discriminative
discriminative in this particular model and we can
look at the relationship to other variables
of interest for example symptom categories
and you know some interesting things emerge so for
example if we look at healthy and schizophrenia
we can see that the symptoms scores kind of
have this this gradient where you have more
severe and least severe and the least severe or
closer to the controls again the model here knew
nothing about symptoms we're just mapping those
symptoms onto these projections you know post hoc
and and this is the last one i promise so so here
here we're looking at a four-way classification
using again a deep learning model um and uh when
we apply the projection we found this interesting
uh result here where the schizoaffective group was
split into two different clusters right one that
was closer to the other groups and one was kind
of off on its own um and you can see that the
symptom scores don't help you a whole lot there's
there's evidence that maybe there's there's a
pretty big spread here in this group as there are
in that group um but these kinds of visualizations
you know and we're looking we're kind of working
currently on some different ways to do this
but trying to visualize well what is unique
about those folks that are misclassified or
folks that are sort of well classified um and
can we look at that in some sort of a continuous
type of measure so in summary um you
know there's a lot of information
that we've mostly been ignoring um that we can
obtain when we when we focus on subgroups of data
or subspaces within our data um if we focus on
this sort of homogeneity and heterogeneity aspect
it can really enhance our sensitivity to relevant
information for example severity of illness
and as the data sets are growing uh more and more
open data sets are available now this gives us an
opportunity to help us try to advance our
ability to characterize mental illness and
and replicate these these results um so you
know just just a slide here to mention that
we we try to release our our methods um we've
got a number of toolboxes that release that
that implement the approaches uh that that
i have mentioned in the previous slides
um and you know we like many others are
a big promo proponents of data sharing um
uh and also data capture in sort of systematic
ways and so we have a system called coins which
sort of all-inclusive does imaging and
assessments and radiology reviews um
but interesting an interesting piece of that is
um sort of complement to that is decentralized
analysis so with these sort of large studies you
know if you want to do an analysis you you have
to you know have a bunch of infrastructure and
download everything or you have to have a cloud
account or access that account and if you want
to combine it with a data set from somewhere
somewhere else you have to get them in the
same place or find a way to do them separately
even more so if you want to work with groups like
enigma where about half of their data sets cannot
be centrally aggregated you can't analyze them
with more complicated type algorithms unless
you have approaches that can you know do analysis
in sort of a decentralized way by passing around
metrics from data set to data set we have
a tool we built called coinstack which is
open source uh and and does this sort of
analysis and so that's kind of an aside
if you're interested you can check it out here
um the work in in that i presented today is is
uh basically i just have to thank uh the folks
at the trend center many collaborators that we
work with and our funding sources and also thank
you very much for for bearing with me i think i'm
about on time uh and without further ado i guess
jack will take some questions now unshare my
screen uh you can just uh just unshare your screen
so we can see you that would be just fine um vince
firstly thank you so much for kind of going
through um you know just really a remarkable
amount of work from from you and your team and
from all your collaborators i mean it's really
quite uh impressive uh amount of firepower you
guys bring to all this i was um as we're kind
of waiting for a few more people to to fire off
some questions i was very interested in about
finding out a little bit more about the spatially
constrained ica um i suppose i've always been a
little bit concerned about ica's ability to um for
on convergence and comparability across subjects
and whether or not the ica analytics solutions are
mathematically unique and it sounds like spatially
constrained ica may help with that um and maybe
get a little more network uh consistency across
groups i was just kind of curious if that was one
of the motivating factors behind the the spatial
constrained ica or if i if i'm off base here yeah
i mean that's that that is uh you know the ability
to kind of run this on individual subjects and
have comparability across uh components i mean
the the the you know the group i see a framework
uh that we've been using for years is kind of a
way to get at that too um basically what you're
doing is saying i'm interested in comparing data
sets and therefore i'm imposing up front this type
of this group model right and this is kind of the
reverse of that which is um you know in the sort
of standard group ica approach you know you are
running a group map and then you're reconstructing
individual and comparable sets of components from
individual subjects right so within that data
set things are comparable and and things work
well and we can get the same answer if we run it
multiple times you know assuming we do these um
you know sort of we we do these repeat
analyses to kind of get guarantee that
um but if you want to cross validate or analyze
data outside of that initial data set you you you
know up up till now have had to basically resort
to running another ica and then figuring out kind
of how it matches and it may not right or just
throwing away the ic model ica model and just
going to like a regression based uh approach and
so we were interested in sort of leveraging the
benefits of ica and maximizing independence and
having all those guarantees but also allowing
us to do this outside of that original
data set and so that's kind of where where
it led us in that direction and so we've been
running you know all sorts of analyses now with
that and the other thing that's nice is you
can do a bunch of stuff within your study
but if you do another study and do something
completely different you can compare right
across those studies if you use those techniques
um so it's quite it's quite nice i i at least
i like it a lot but you guys can try it out
we have the maps up there on our website
and there's a paper which i think it has
neural mark in the name it talks about it
um and so feel free to try and it's built into the
gif tools as well you can just click on it and run
it on one subject if you want what were the um
you know you've had the benefit of having some
pretty remarkable sample sizes to be able to put
through some of your methods um especially with
some of the i'm sure this is important not only
for ica but also some of the by clustering stuff
you talked about there are several of those big
data sets like the human connectome project or
abcd for development um you mentioned the
uk biobank i think um somewhere in there
what sort of sample sizes do we kind of
need to have i mean i'm thinking the uk
biobank is just a ridiculous amount of data
but obviously that's kind of a rare resource
but what sort of sample sizes do you guys look
for when you're trying to run ica kind of analyses
i mean with you in terms of what you need
well i think it really depends on what you
what questions you're asking okay um and
uh i i don't think there's a minimum per se
i would say if you're interested in individual
prediction you know sort of accuracy scores
in a binary classification case then you
know more is better right because you um
you know you you can um there's a you know
there's a certain variance that you have to
account for around your accuracy and and you're
kind of bounded by that if you say you have
you know 100 subjects and your variance is five
percent right plus or minus five percent or plus
or minus ten percent well that can be a pretty big
difference right if you're talking about clinical
guiding clinical decisions right and so the
the more you can ramp up that data the more you
can reduce that and be more confident in in the
answer but so i guess i would say there but that
doesn't mean that you're not learning some useful
information from from the smaller data set um so
i guess i i think it really does depend on what
you're predicting and how large that effect is
in the data it's why we've kind of tried to
look at group effects and are they rough do
they replicate you know things like that so i
was going to say that one of the but i'm not yeah
but i'm not you know and again like if you're
predicting behavior and behavior is highly
variable uh then that's gonna that's gonna be
your rate limiting step right your rate limiting
you know part of that study is the fact that you
know you your your correlations like you know on
average 0.2 right or 0.3 yeah that's going to be
hard to predict right with with you know any any
level of accuracy so on your spatiotemporal
dynamics application uh i was particularly
interested in that and i was just kind of curious
if you've noticed uh how the variability spatially
is structured like for example is it cyto or
tectonically constrained um every are you notice
any things that like that um and also does the
time scale play an important role of the data
acquisition yeah so so you know we i would like
i'm pretty sure there will be some interesting
cyto architectonic links there but we haven't
tackled that per se just you know i would i would
do it if we had a 7t scanner and try to get it you
know so i think the layer specific stuff can help
a little bit with that it doesn't get you cyto
arc tectonics but it gets you a little bit of
input output right and things like that right um
you know so we've been looking more at sort of the
macro scale right because we're kind of working
with more standard 3t data sets uh at this point
i think the time scale does matter um and you you
see things that are kind of as i showed in that
state line analysis you know the the drop off
of the you know hanging together of the state
is is much faster right in in the patients
than it is in the than it is in the controls
um and you know there's a lot of interesting
um elements that you can glean from from delay
uh as well i i think you know ultimately we also
have to remember that we're looking at again very
macroscopic level data and we you know there i
didn't really get into sort of multimodal but we
can you can do multimodal you know analysis
and collect multiple types of data from
from the same person and then if you have a
number of subjects with those same data types
you can start to try to link those scales together
um and that can give you more information as well
and i think there's a lot you can do there
that's great are you aware of any efforts to
apply models like the ones you've described to
patients that do or do not respond to therapies
um i'm sure that i'm sure that yes i
i've certainly come across some of those
um so the idea would be like selecting individuals
who would be most responsive right so that would
be the potential one potential scenario where
you could use it we've talked a lot about
um just in the context of not necessarily therapy
but treatment uh in general you know are you know
can you pre-select individuals who are more likely
to be responsive right to a given treatment right
um uh and so but yeah i mean i think that would be
we i haven't done that myself um looking at sort
of uh response to therapy i think there's some
data where at the mind research network um eric
klaus and katie wickowitz were are looking at sort
of uh cognitive behavioral therapy and mindfulness
and some other measures like that um and so that
will be eventually something where we can try
you know try that on um but yeah i think i mean
i think that's a great area um to apply this to
that's great now one of the things which is
always seems to be a you mentioned rate limiting
factors is it's uh individuals don't often have
necessarily access to high performance compute
clusters at their institutions for whatever reason
or they maybe they're you know not really fully
bought into you know giving money to amazon i
was curious if you might tell us a little bit
more about coinstack sure yeah so so what we're
doing there is um and we call it decentralized
learning i think google calls it federated
learning um essentially what we're doing is
um you download this application and you map your
data to it so you maybe map your structural mri
data to it and then you you see consortia and
you can join a consortia right so suppose you
and five of your friends download coinstack and
somebody creates a consortia you know and and
you you join that right uh and then the consortia
creator sets up an analytic model or a computation
and that might be do uh a vbm analysis of these
data or it could be a free surfer analysis or
it could be we have group ica in there as well
this this sort of spatially constrained group ica
um and then you know uh and then what happens
is that the in the you know they specify which
variables are needed for the analysis and then
the individual um sites uh see those variables
and they map their you know do the mapping of
their variables to those right so the names
uh match they don't have to match but you you
match the ver the data right uh and uh and then
you click go and then it runs the analysis locally
so basically it takes that analysis and it runs
uh locally without moving the data it produces
some derivatives potentially adds noise to that
and then aggregates it privately and can
iterate you know so you can you know you
may need just one iteration you may need many
depending on what what you're doing if it's just
a regression one will be enough um if it's
like a support vector machine you need more
um and and then you get a global you know answer
uh to that uh solution and so that that you know
again has multiple benefits you know and it's
complementary if you can put all your data in one
place and have everything and have access to all
of it and run it uh there that would be great but
you know sometimes you don't have the resources
sometimes the data can't be shared right so
you're collaborating with somebody and they're not
allowed to we we have a data set um this this f
burn data set that that i've been showing a lot
here um we've been arguing with the irb for you
know for over a decade trying to get them to allow
us to share it and they will not let us share it
and because it didn't have you know data sharing
language in there when it was collected which was
way before you know this became common yeah um and
so you know there may be cases where you have rare
disorders or you have identifiable information
other kinds of data that you're looking at that
might be sensitive and so i think it's a useful
complement and you can imagine connecting that to
large pool data as well so pool what you
can and bring in what you can right right
are there any hardware requirements that uh
if someone wanted to become a coin stack uh
a node in your system would they have any um
it's at the moment it's just run on individual
analyses and so it really depends on what you
want to run okay so so you know and at the
rate limiting step is how much local data you're
analyzing so if you're if you're analyzing a lot
of data locally you need to have enough storage
for that data and enough computation to run it so
it's whatever your local scale happens to be right
yeah right exactly but you don't need to scale it
to the entire amount of data that you're analyzing
across all the sites um and um the other thing
where we've got um we're sort of working on this
now we've got it sort of a sort of a pre-alpha
version of it is is like a sort of a headless coin
stack i guess i'll call it which is if i have a um
you know a data set and i just want to make it
open right for point stack people so you can't
get the data but you can always see the coin stack
node and you can control the mapping right and run
the analysis then that that and that would be a
great for some of these larger data sets where you
want to provide a resource right for the for the
community or a benchmark for people or you know
etc and so that i think is is something that could
be hosted um and potentially should should require
maybe a data center if you're going to have a lot
of people using it right right are there any um is
it all or nothing either you're you're you know
only say sharing like statistical results or the
raw data or not at all or are there kind of levels
of of granularity of what you can be shared um
so yeah it depends again on the computation you
do so so there's a there's a couple levels like
you can you can make consortia private if
you want so so only your friends can join
um you can you can pick an algorithm that sort
of passes derivatives like maybe it passes
gradient weights or maybe it passes you know beta
values or something like that right you can also
do something called differential privacy which
it takes the derivative and maybe you feel like
i don't even want people that i'm worried that
people might machine learn on my data right and
figure out even though it's it's it's you know
not that informative they might still be able to
put those pieces together right and so uh with
differential privacy allows you to add some some
some noise structured noise to it that then
gets sort of averaged out when you do the
uh the aggregation and and we even have another
one that that's using encryption now which is
basically sort of bank level encryption um
where we you encrypt the derivatives before
you share them and then you learn on the encrypted
derivatives so there's different there's different
levels there that we're we're working towards for
sure because different people will have different
needs so what is next in the world of big data
brain science in this space i think i don't know
there's so much to do here i mean i i
feel like um i think we're learning a
lot but i also i guess what i the things
that i worry about i guess i'll say are
there's too much turning of the crank without
thinking about what's underneath the crank right
and and so um for example i i like the i mean i
love all this i love the fact that there's a lot
of data available but i'm also wary that you know
there's a lot of reuse and studies are going to
start to be correlated to one another right yeah
and another thing is that if everybody uses the
same pipeline right to process their data you've
baked in biases right so think about by you know
biological diversity right analytical diversity is
probably good too it's not necessarily a bad thing
um and it can give you some benefits it can
give you um you know some information right um
i do think that um that they're you know things
are accelerating and i feel hopeful about
um having brain imaging lead towards
some some more useful clinical
tools um you know before too long because i feel
like we're sort of getting getting a better handle
on you know replicability and um generalizability
and and things like that you know still
still working on that but these large studies
are helping that's great well and then yeah i'm
still like we're doing a lot with deep learning
yeah um and i think again developing models that
are interpretable so one of the one of the
ways that we're doing that is we're taking
ica which one of the things i like about it is
i find it somewhat interpretable to get out you
know multiple networks that interact you know with
one another and so you can build that inside of a
deep learning model right and then start to look
at um instead of just this sort of massive set of
of you know hundreds of thousands of weights you
now have them segregated by networks you can look
at subspaces that was kind of what i was getting
at with the complexity analysis i showed um so
anyway there's just a few things someone else will
give you a completely different answer probably
that's undoubtedly the case well uh vince
calhoun thank you so much for for joining
us and sharing your work with us uh an amazing
amount of work and what an amazing team you have
and i hope everything is going well for
you after the big move to georgia but uh
anyway thank you everybody who joined us
and we look forward to seeing you next week
thanks again vince appreciate it my
pleasure it's pleasure to be here take